-How are you?
-I'm great. How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations on the first
season of "The Conners."
-Yeah.
-This show was "Roseanne."
And then, it wasn't.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, Roseanne, you know,
she was relieved of her duties,
so to speak.
How has it been, you know --
Obviously,
you still have Laurie Metcalf,
you still have Sara Gilbert.
Has it been strange
without Roseanne around?
-It was.
It was -- It was really odd.
She's a -- We used to have
a lot of fun on the show,
and I really missed her
this year.
-Yeah. I can only imagine
what it's like.
I mean, certainly,
there were things she was doing
outside the show which
ultimately led to her leaving,
but the product the first year
really did have
that old snap to it.
-Well, she -- she gave up a lot
so that we could do the show.
She gave up
all her rights to it.
So we didn't have
to call ourselves the Monners
or the Chonners
or anything like that...
-Yeah.
-...and invent new characters.
But, yeah,
she will always be missed.
-One of the things that people
loved about the reboot
of the show
is it took issues seriously,
and up to and including the fact
that Roseanne
was written off the show.
Her character
died of an opioid overdose.
-Yeah.
-You know, and that --
You just kind of say,
"Oh, gosh.
You guys went into it
headlong like that.
Were you surprised that
that's how they handled it?
-I was.
That's pretty permanent.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean,
when I died on the show,
they just brought me back.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're back, yeah.
-They're not gonna remember.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody was watching
toward the end.
He was sleeping.
-And some pretty great
guest stars this year.
-Yeah.
-Mary Steenburgen.
Peter Gallagher.
Katey Sagal.
The fabulous Estelle Parsons.
-Fantastic. Yeah.
-She's amazing.
But, yeah.
We got good people on the show.
And I know I've forgotten...
half of --
-You'll hear from them.
-I put it in the variety.
-Yeah, that's great.
We were talking backstage,
your old former castmate,
Jeff Bridges, was on stage,
winning an award
at the Golden Globes.
And, you know,
there were multiple clips
of "The Big Lebowski"
in his honor.
Is that the film that people
approach you about the most?
-Yep.
-Yeah.
-It's a good one, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I did one called "C.H.U.D."
that gets a lot of airplay.
-"C.H.U.D."?
-Yeah.
-Cannibalistic --
-Cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers.
-Yeah.
"C.H.U.D." was a big deal.
I worked in a rental store
and "C.H.U.D." was a big deal.
[ Laughter ]
Back when people had to go
to a store to get a movie, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But, I mean, people must --
I would assume that when people
interact with you
on "The Big Lebowski,"
they also --
they want to yell
lines of dialogue.
-And they do.
-Yeah.
What do you hear the most?
-"Shut the [bleep] up, Donny."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
See, that's --
I mean,
I guess that's a weird thing,
because obviously
they're doing that out of love,
but in doing it,
they're screaming,
"Shut the [bleep] up," to you.
-It's not as bad as when Buscemi
gets it on the street.
-Yeah, that's true.
Poor Steve Buscemi.
I, of course --
It was a Coen Brothers film.
But I believe maybe
the first time I saw you
was "Raising Arizona,"
which is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I will say both of those --
-Yeah.
-Both of those movies
hold up so well,
because they really weren't
specific to the time
they were made.
-Were they big rentals?
-They were huge rentals, yeah.
-They got rewound?
-Yeah, yeah.
They got rewound a lot.
-Yeah, Coen Brothers watchers,
they'll rewind.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They really do rewind well.
You got hit with one
of those blue --
-Lawsuit?
-No, no, not a lawsuit.
[ Laughter ]
You robbed some bank.
-Yeah.
-And one of those blue pellets.
-As a special effect,
was that one of the better ones
you've been involved in?
-It was great.
Yeah, it was great.
I think we only did it twice,
because of the hours
it involved in cleaning up.
-Yeah.
It was a teller put a bomb into
the bag of money and fooled us.
Which was --
Never mind.
[ Laughter ]
-No, but...
I mean, it was the greatest
thing, because it exploded
not just on you guys
but also on the windshield.
-Yeah.
And we were trying to drive.
Go see the movie, folks.
[ Laughter ]
-Out now.
-Rent it.
-And rewind it.
-Rewind it.
Be kind and rewind.
You -- What were the movies --
I mean, 'cause again,
that was a really inspirational
movie for me growing up.
What were yours?
What were the films that you saw
as a kid that made you --
-"On The Waterfront."
I loved it,
and it made me
want to try to act.
-And did you ever meet Brando?
-No.
I would've --
No. I'm better off.
-Better off, yeah.
You don't think --
Because did he continue to be
someone who was
very important to you?
-Absolutely. Yeah.
Especially when
I was starting off.
But you can't
steal everything from him.
-Yeah.
-'Cause you wind up doing
really bad imitations.
"Um..."
[ Laughter ]
-You did Brando on "SNL," yes?
-Yeah, I did.
-Yeah.
-"Jeopardy!"
-Oh, right.
-"Celebrity Jeopardy!"
Yeah.
-With Turd Ferguson.